et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les deux scènes et nouba chic de beverly
hills est né de leur talent et cette
amende à être caché sa volonté bol dans
son slip à retour de clément la crue ce
nom avec toi défi et moi la crise qui
bosse avec nous il avait un défi sans le
moindre billet arrive à s'incruster à
serrer la main du président de la cre au
stade de france en ait mais c'est énorme
ça on va voir si la rue ça on va voir ça
tout à l'heure mais il a réussi
maintenant je veux voir ça je suis là
pour commencer une machine caf
comment s'est aussi fait pâle ou la
téloche ce week-end avec les 24 heures
télé spéciale eurovision lorsqu'on a pu
mater que ça vu que ça dure 24 heures
l'albanie nous défoncer n'y a que là où
l'albanie nos gagnants regarde c'est
vrai que l'albanie
commenter la cérémonie avec stéphane
bern et christophe il trouve que tout le
monde est heureux et les mines et
directe au ni oui ni non ni contente on
est content quand il est content d'aller
contempler les contes anciens vie
des content quand même pourtant on lui
dit content parce que c'est comme ça
représente au portugal on a vu l'enfant
de stars de mokhtar et cyril arielle
dombasle qui a passé une tête aussi
riels tortue géniale et elle a également
la soie tortue géniale
moundir entre deux aventures à donner de
la voix il était à fond sa taille et on
a vu le fils de nicolas sarkozy et
jean-louis mélenchon rapidement
si le gars qui sait pas s'il est
conforme ou pas c'est qu'il sait pas il
est content il n'est pas content il est
constant il n'est pas content pin est
content il est pas content pour donner
leur vote les oignons envoyer une
personne qui transpire la joie de vivre
ils ont bien fait stéphane bern l'ami
des stars il a vu un tweet en direct de
ling renault mais alors où c'est un
mytho line renaud à la 1200 caractère
elle pour ses tweets j'ai déjà un tweet
line renaud écrit je croise les doigts
pour madame monsieur qui m'ont écrit tu
lui une très belle chanson sur mon album
rue washington
ils sont super je le souhaite le plus
grand succès par sms et appels et voici
la chanteuse qui a emballé tout le monde
la vraie gagnante de cet eurovision
[Musique]
bissonnet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
brocade la kia guillaume tc aussi qui
avait vu tout ce truc ça ouais la caf et
le meilleur c'est les croise on est
qu'il adore fantas alors lui on lui un
bisou m et benjamin castaldi n'est pas
mal même si l'image il a trouvé son look
elle a trouvé son style s'est pas vu sur
l'autoroute du bonheur à nat la natte
la nasa lui a bien faire pour rendre
hommage à l'eurovision on aller dans la
rue rencontrer des gens qui n'avaient
pas suivi la cérémonie pour leur faire
écouter la chanson du gagnant sauf qu'on
a créé un faux duo avec une fausse
chanson qu'on appelait chtouille and on
a le groupe qu'est la voilà on a créé 5
4 millions s'il pense que c'est bien ou
pas ce morceau de mokhtar et moi
photo image tout y est
il parle des couilles c'est un belle
musique
ce super ça va c'est cool en vrai en
vrai ça peut passer sur un malentendu
c'est top je me vois bien sûr la piscine
tranquille cet entraînement pourrait
peut-être changer les paroles ça parle
d'une maladie comme un lâche tout
ces virus oui j'aime bien et quand vous
avez reconnu que c'était des ruches j'ai
peint driss moi-même morisod vous aimez
l'eurovision vous regarder tout ça c'est
un rendez vous familial
changez pas de site en fait ce revers
n'est qu'un concept à moi j'adore mais
il ya une révolution une révélation
alors hop house et almac était super
aussi le père oui à l'aise et vous
l'avez été 7e bien c'est super c'était
pour parler ceiling on mettra les notes
d y aura sur leur vision dans un asile
où bach web vous le savez c'est la
période où tu entends des gens te dire
aux l'espace et cannes puis on se fin
des jo c'est vrai c'est le feu en ce
moment sur la croisette on a envie de
remettre une petite balade
c'est sur france 2 dans télématin tu
sens que sophie le saint
la journaliste à l'état afin une grande
cinéphile passionné par cannes en même
temps une fine gastronomie
car paradis égérie étaient présents bien
sûr guidé par la sublime kate blanquette
c'est aussi cette ravissante jeune femme
l'état invite à monter les marches du
festival devant les milliers de caméras
regarder troisième marche sa foi et à la
marche d'après deuxième essai sun notre
été il faut mettre monte-escalier stana
dans ce palais dont le gall m6 on l'a vu
ce qu'on n'aurait jamais aimé voir ma
caisse vie en slip
non ah oui c'est vrai de traces que
longo sexy chocolat ont des temps et on
et guînes
regardez le il est en legging juste
après ah oui apparemment ils avaient
emmené un petit qu'installe qu'il avait
bien caché le match à bordeaux je fonce
pas et merci à tous ceux qui m'ont
envoyé sept enfants de stars vraiment
c'est les meilleurs sur internet de
copargo darrigade
il était chez nagui regard des plus
casse verte des voyages scolaires en vo
version gimat les jt aussi mon sur l'a7
à dents mais toi tu adores lalana le
futur hôtel à l'information
foot ça vous l'avez peut-être vu cette
image elle est incroyable dans le
journal de france 2 il ya une jeune
fille qui en duplex en plus un sujet
très sérieux mais pour des raisons
inexpliquées elle a bloqué littéralement
essais liquéfier complètement pendant le
duplex sera vous rassurez vous elle va
beaucoup mieux l'animateur a tout appris
du réel elle a eu peur un coup de stress
regarder une conférence de presse que la
famille souhaite la plus digne possible
face à
[Musique]
angélique ils ont l'intention de porter
plusieurs plaintes c'est ça
oui dès demain il ne pense voilà j'ai
regardé jean pierre pernaut aussi dans
le 13 heures tu événement foot la
semaine dernière c'était bien sûr la
finale de coupe de france psg face à
l'équipe des herbiers
ouais on a voulu suivre au plus près cet
événement donc on a envoyé notre pote
clémente incruste avec un seul défi
rentrer dans le stade de france sans
billet et serrer la main de notre
président emmanuel macron alors qu'il a
rien à faire là évidemment il a été bon
on a les images mais avant de l'envoyer
au stade quand même pour que clément
passe inaperçu on a commencé par une
petite séance de stylisme sont là les
images
est-ce qu'on a ouais voilà petite séance
de stylisme essayer de trouver
évidemment le meilleur look qui lui
rappelle ses lui trouver les fun
parfaite pour s'incruster on a longtemps
hésité pour ce stade pas griller on a
finalement choisi le même survêt que
l'équipe des herbiers au tennis et plus
simple il a commencé par se fondre parmi
les supporters on l'a vu pendant duplex
sur ces news aux abords du stade pour
chauffer
deux heures et demie du coup d'envoi
maintenant ils sont nombreux les
supporters de van der vaart et de
déplacement aujourd'hui alors
certainement avec vincent et sa famille
ont fait le déplacement ce matin mais
pas comme en france il pendant que les
parisiens faisaient leur entrée dans
l'enceinte clément il s'est fait passer
pour un membre du staff des herbiers et
s'est retrouvé sur la pelouse
si l'on mange pas ranger les ballons en
l'air de rien mais ensuite j'ai commencé
carrément à checker les jouets à elle
est encouragée pour qu'ils gagnent et sa
croissance en tout le monde pense qui
fait partie du staff qui commence à
entraîner les gardiens a carrément
autant il est filmé par les caméras de
france télé les herbes y ont perdu le
match malheureusement leur public
regardez cet événement s'est libéré mais
à la fin du match j'ai fleurent didier
ira sur son équipe bien sûr irak royal
par faire le tour du stade de france
avec toute l'équipe est perdu la reine
sony qui s'improvisent avec toute
l'équipe des herbiers et devinez qui
ferme la queue leu leu et basse et
d'autres très bons c'est ont regardé au
moment où le psg l'est de la coupe
clément et même au premier rang pour les
féliciter parce qu'il est fair play ne
fait pas avec tous savent de l'étude
[Applaudissements]
samcam déjà ça on peut le dire c'est une
fille un peu rappelé qu'ils n'avaient
pas de billets n'avaient rien ils
étaient diffusés en plus sur france 2
début sur france
les herbiers est incroyable la question
que tout le monde se pose la question
mais le président reste entière clément
at il serrait la main d' emmanuel macron
présent dans les tribunes
voici les images au moment où l'équipe
des herbiers montant tribune pour
récupérer leurs médailles de finalistes
tellement mérité
témoin est là aussi justice il aurait
fallu chemin de la première dame et
attention attention attention impact
c'est un énorme coup de la gamme
la fête dans les vestiaires regarder il
a testé cette soirée avec edinson cavani
même celle ci avec neymar non oh là là
et merci avec du désherbant merveille
les sablés et non me garder mais on fait
pas nous on est dernier avec l'éditeur
possible d'être relégué laissait ses
très bons nous ont aidés comme des
malades pour quoi elle va faire ça merci
à tout le staff des hommes des airs leur
avait été dit on a fait le maximum avec
alice est allé serrer la main du
président clément le serial killer
c'est très grave quand même alors elle a
le soulève un lièvre il a réussi
heureusement c'est clément la cruche pas
de galère c'était sympa
[Applaudissements]
et non pas ce à quoi un exploit tri sur
la pelouse du stade c'est tout moi même
dans la za jardin public j'avais joué